a platform which terminates apps on its
own is a pretty radical departure for
anyone like me who cut their teeth on
desktop WinForms development if you come
from a similar background you probably
have a pretty good idea of what to
expect in terms of lifecycle event
handles you start with the oncreate
callback where you build and wire up
your UI
once that's done your activity has been
created it likely won't be a surprise to
you that there are also event handlers
for when the activity becomes visible
which is onstart and another for when it
gets focus and becomes the active
foreground app which is on resume that
same sequence then happens in Reverse on
pause indicates that the activity has
lost focus followed by on stop when the
app is not visible finally there's a non
destroy method indicating the end of the
app lifecycle when your app is first
launched you'll quickly move through
these states create start resume one
after the other but within the full
application lifetime from when on create
is first called until the app is finally
terminated
it will move through the active life
time and the visible lifetime many times
let's look at those in a little more
detail